whew all right so this is the day after
the election
um chances are so i'm recording this
show a few weeks before the election
chances are there's not even a decision
maybe
um but it seems like everybody's gearing
up for this thing to go for a long time
i lived through bush gore
and the cali
do the like the the neutron bomb
of diarrhea that that was and that is my
second diarrhea reference of the show
and i don't even care
um so i'm hoping that's not the case i
hope there's a clear
answer this morning when we all woke up
um but there may not be
but here's the deal so it's a day after
the election
everybody's gonna exhale or everybody
woke up and they inhaled
but here's here's my rules for moving
forward and you didn't ask for him but
this is
you are listening to this podcast so you
can feel free to
to click off if you don't hear my rules
but here they are number one
if you didn't vote you are silent for
the next four years you don't get to
play
you chose to sit on the sidelines and go
yeah get them get them but you didn't do
anything you never even got on the field
so for four years you have to just be
quiet you have to write poems and plant
gardens
and make your truck louder whatever the
thing is that you want to do
the if you did vote here's a couple of
choices you have
you can choose to gloat and be an idiot
and be like yeah we showed them
congratulations
we didn't show anybody anything you
voted your one vote
we all voted our one vote and your
candidate won
great we're all still on the same team
gloating is number one number two if
your candidate didn't win
you could take your ball and go home i'm
sad and i'm gonna pout and i'm gonna
throw a fit and i'm gonna demand this
and i'm going to
look that's not gonna solve any problems
either
you can take your ball and go home i
don't like how we're playing
but you voted you played and that means
we're all in it together
okay the third option which is i hope
everyone does is we can say all right
whoever won
won period i'm not going to fold my
business up i'm not going to pull all my
money out of the market i'm not going to
dump all my money back into the
i'm going to choose to live locally
which is the only thing i can i can do
like i can actually get my hands on the
only people i can get my arms around to
hug
and to care for and i'm going to work
really hard to make my local community
better and stronger
and more resilient i don't care which
side of the political
aisle you are on in this thing we all
know this is out of control
and we've all been in yelling fights
before or fist fights before
or kickboxing matches before where we
feel it getting too hot
and it's hard to back out well it's the
day after the election
let's everybody just stop
stop and look at the person driving next
to you right now look at the person
mowing their yard in the
the grass in the in the yard next to you
and recognize them as a husband
or a daughter or a father or a mother
as as the owner of a cat for god's sakes
right
the owner of a dog let's acknowledge him
as people and we have to figure this out
together
and a executive politician is not going
to solve
kindness issues it's not going to solve
basic humanity issues
it's not going to solve the bajillions
of trillions of dollars that we all
collectively owe
guys it's my freaking grandkids are
gonna have to figure out what to do with
that
it's my grandkids it's my children and
it pisses me off
enough with it
it's not our executive politicians are
going to solve our nutritional issues
and our movement issues and our mental
health challenges they're just
not that crap's going gonna get solved
with us and so it's the day after the
election
everybody spit your mouthpieces out put
your gloves down
on the mats and let's look across the
arena the people we've been
swinging and kicking and punching and
biting
and kneeing and elbowing and all of it
and let's just say
we're done same team same team
let's don't gloat let's don't pick up
our tennis rackets and go home
same team i want you to find somebody
that you have not been cool to that
you've been a jerk to that you've
ignored
a family member that you told off
halfway through the election cycle
i want you to call them today and say
hey i love you and i'm sorry
i want you to swear off any sort of
political nonsense for a couple of days
re-center i want you to send an email to
your boss and say hey i appreciate you
holding everything together
send an email to your co-workers or a
handwritten letter of your coworkers and
say hey thanks for
weathering this season with us we got a
lot of hard work to do let's go get it
done
no gloating no pouting guys we gotta
solve this together
these are our kids these are our
grandkids
these are us let's go make it right okay
it's the day after the election
hope we still are all here i'm assuming
we are i hope the election's been
decided i don't know who won that's why
i'm doing this on the front end
but whatever happened let's work
together
let's work together